hello and welcome to the Newseum in
Arlington Virginia for this week's close
up at the Newseum discussion of war
we're going to be talking with a war
correspondent who's written a few
fascinating books on the subject of war
and about the mythology surrounding the
concept also joining us today are
students from MacLean high school and
also students are I should not say
students but young professionals who are
part of the leadership training program
at the Center for Strategic and
International Studies and we'll meet
some of them and hear their questions
and comments in just the moments first
let me introduce you to our guest
joining us is Chris Hedges chris is a
veteran war correspondent who was a
member of the reporting team at the New
York Times in 2001 that was awarded the
Pulitzer Prize for their coverage of
global terrorism he's also written for
the Christian Science Monitor and the
Dallas Morning News and is reported for
National Public Radio he's the author of
several books including what every
person should know about war and war is
a force that gives us meaning here are
those two books also his most recent
book is titled losing Moses on the
freeway which is about the ten
commandments good morning and welcome to
the discussion thanks let me let me ask
you first about your your journalistic
history how did you become a war
correspondent how did you get into that
line of work through a very circuitous
route I I never studied journalism I
went to Harvard Divinity School
graduated with a Master of Divinity came
out of a family my father was a
Presbyterian minister but very involved
in social activism and I had a hard time
growing up in the church reconciling the
quote/unquote objective nature of
journalism with the social activism that
was very much a part of my family and my
upbringing and I became very drawn to
Latin America in the early 1980s when
military governments were carrying out
terrible repression against their own
citizens Pinochet and Chile the dirty
war in Argentina where 30,000 of its own
citizens were disappeared by the
military junta and went off to Latin
America to be a freelance reporter
actually went off and covered the war in
El Salvador when I graduated from
seminary in certainly not because I
wanted to write on behalf of any side or
any ideology but because the repression
itself was so severe and the issues of
social justice issues were so pronounced
that it was something I wanted to cover
and you mentioned your dad was a
Presbyterian minister additionally he
was a world war two veteran yes and what
kind of impact I mean what's your
earliest memory of thinking about your
father's role in that war and then I
think I remember that he was a protester
against the Vietnam War especially my
dad was in North Africa and the Middle
East
landed at Casablanca and really hated
war and hated the military and and war
he went into service so I you know I
think like most idealistic young men at
the time and I think that's true with
any generation really had no idea of
what war was but it was you know that
the influence of World War two was
greater than just my father's experience
because on both sides of the family all
of my uncle's with the exception of one
fought in the war and one was in the
South Pacific he was actually in the
army before the war started so was in
the South Pacific from 1939 to 99 1944
where he was finally badly wounded and
came back and he never recovered from
the war he emotionally and physically
you know of course in those days the
word post-traumatic stress disorder
didn't exist it wasn't even coined until
1974 but he had terrible problems with
alcoholism he couldn't hold his marriage
together he couldn't hold down a job and
this was a small town in Maine where he
you know would work for one of my
uncle's in the lumber mill to you know
get money as soon as he got his check
disappear for two or three days and he
was a real burden to the family
especially growing up in a manse where
there was no alcohol and I think that
you know looking back on it there were
probably tens of thousands of American
families who were caring for
shattered wrecks of veterans like that
but it was not spoken about publicly and
these people were essentially blamed for
their own trauma and shunted aside so
the war was a pervasive presence in my
life and
none of my uncle's or my father were
pacifists but they they did everything
they could to deflate the myth of war
the idea that it was about glory and
honor and and all those abstract terms
that in the moment of combat become
hollow if not obscene so this is a
notion that's been with you for quite
some time yes in the abstract it's one
thing to hear that it's another thing to
walk into a firefight in El Salvador and
experience it you know within recent
years we've seen things like The
Greatest Generation Tom Brokaw's book
the unveiling of the world war 2
memorial a couple weeks ago here we had
a couple of World War two correspondence
ed s sortir and Jack pullers and we and
we had an audience that was at least
half world war two veterans and you
would almost think it was a good time it
is that sort of comradeship that you
write about and heroic memories and
telling tales of glory it's almost the
modern version of the classics of
antiquity talking about the heroic ideal
well you know we every generation
mythologize --is the war that went
before you know all those kids who went
off to world war ii had held up before
them the myth of World War one and of
course before that it was the myth of
the Civil War the the you know wars are
venal dirty horrible business especially
in the 20th century where we have
created essentially a mechanism of
industrial slaughter where you know
thousands of enemy combatants can die
without even seeing the people who are
attacking them so this is an Achilles
with a sword this is Achilles 30,000
feet above exactly pushing a bull though
of course you know if you go back and
read the Iliad
Homer was very aware of this process and
there's a speech in the Iliad by nestor
where he talks about you know the Age of
Heroes the age of the Giants I mean
there has always been that and and and
it is a myth because World War two was
as brutal and horrific and horrifying as
any war again let me reiterate that I'm
especially having lived in Sarajevo
during the siege I'm not a pacifist but
but war is is always tragic and I think
in many ways those people who have an
interest in perpetuating war of have an
interest in maintaining the myth but the
myth itself is also what people like it
you see it it's pervasive within the
entertainment industry at television
with movies it's very hard for reporters
to report outside of the myth by that I
mean to report on just the the brutal
consequences of war itself you know
there is always an attempt to search for
the hometown hero I mean this is how we
end up with the fabricated story about
Jessica Lynch or Pat Tillman and it's
not just the war makers who spin out
those myths for public consumption but
the press that seizes upon it because
those myths sell newspapers it's how
William Randolph Hearst of course built
his empire and they boost ratings and
that has been true I think since the
creation of the modern war correspondent
in the Crimean War when we got the
Telegraph and in relatively real time
could get accounts of battle doesn't
that need go beyond the the policymakers
and the press though because nobody
rejects these stories are cynical about
them they go down pretty easy it sounds
like people need that as well well
people yearn for them I mean you know it
gives wartime creates its own culture
one that is very destructive to real
culture and certainly to honest
intellectual and journalistic criticism
and self-criticism and there's that
great quote by Senator Hiram Johnson in
1917 that you know when the first
casualty and war is truth it's very hard
with the contagion of the crowd with
that mingling of fear with the
excitement of war I mean I think if you
look at for instance at the build-up to
this war at what constituted the
coverage of the war
it most often comprised interviews with
retired officers who talked about the
power of our weapons systems and of
course by extension our own power so
there is a complicity on the part of the
public at large that feels in noble dand
empowered by this myth patriotism or
let's call it blind patriotism or
nationalism is at its core about self
exaltation and of course with that the
denigration of the other it's why for me
you know rampant nationalism is a
disease one that always embodies an
element of racism now not only racism
towards Iraqis or towards I think in
many ways the rhetoric about Muslims is
in this country has tinges of racism but
even about those who share our values
and our concerns but disagree with us
and we saw this most evidently and
displayed in our reaction to the
criticism from the French we're the
kinds of things that were said about the
French we're really you know I think
racist I mean that we denigrated their
culture we denigrated their identity
their abuses to world war ii exactly and
and and that is is that that's why
nationalism when it sweeps through a
country and and and I'm not singling out
America I've watched this happen in you
know six or seven or eight nations that
I've covered at war you know reduces the
level of debate to sort of a chant and
makes any kind of honest critique or
self-criticism dangerous often
physically dangerous you've used the
term myth it differently what Joseph
Campbell when he wrote and spoke about
mythology or myths would talk about
stories that reveal greater truths maybe
even greater than the facts it seems as
if you're using myth as a lie
yes and I've been taken to task for that
but I think that there is a mythology
about war that does not reveal a greater
there that that mythology Lizza greater
yes but you know but that mythology is
is pervasive with within most societies
the notion that somehow going to war
will test your manhood make a man of you
you know I read a study actually by
military psychiatrists who said that
soldiers who go into combat soldiers and
Marines have go into combat oftentimes
walk away with the trauma equivalent to
someone who was in a car crash where
their best friend was killed that level
of trauma is something that is that Mars
you that emotionally scars you and that
you carry with you for the rest of your
life it is not a matter of manhood are
these war myths essentially I suppose
what I'm hearing you describe is that
they're best they are a survival
mechanism they allow people to live
through this trauma and continue to
function at their worst they become an
enabling device to do horrific things
that are human beings you know I think
that many of the combat veterans who are
honest come back and are often very
alienated within the society because of
course they know the reality of war it
takes about 30 seconds of combat to
realize that all of those myths are
untrue it's why wounded Marines in World
War two G or John Wayne when he visited
them in a hospital and that creates a
kind of distance and you know I go back
to my own family that you know when the
you know my father never walked in the
in the Veterans parade and the fourth of
July not because he wasn't proud of his
service but because he didn't like that
the continuation of that kind of culture
which interestingly enough especially
with the VFW hall in my small town
revolved around drinking and he was
opposed to drink and many of them drank
too much and I think that that there are
many many veterans who come back and and
don't buy into that myth but we don't
hear from them they're not the people we
trot out at the 4th of July because they
don't read from the script so
I think that oftentimes combat veterans
are very split and those that I think
sees most ardently upon this myth either
had a very peripheral role in the
enterprise this is coming from my dad or
oftentimes are so troubled and disturbed
by what they saw on perhaps what they
did that it's either easier to cloak
themselves in the flag and and
patriotism and not deal with their own
demons so tell us the list of conflicts
that you covered firsthand well I was in
Central America for five years so I did
the war in El Salvador Guatemala
Nicaragua then I took a sabbatical and
studied Arabic went off to the Middle
East covered the civil war in the Sudan
Algeria the Persian Gulf War where I was
with 1st battalion 1st Marines went into
Kuwait was eventually in the upper
Shiite uprising in Basra after the war
where I was captured and taken prisoner
by the Iraqi Republican Guard covered
the civil war in Yemen and and then went
in 1995 - sorry AVO to cover the war in
Bosnia and later Kosovo and when you've
written about this and talked about this
you almost described it as drug
addiction yeah oh yeah war was your drug
how did you get off the drug well let me
let me first you know I made sure please
I mean I went off to Central America as
an idealist I you know migrated sort of
model and to this day room you know
remains a writer I deeply respect his
George Orwell I you know I wanted to
give a voice to the victims whether
those victims were being bearing the
brunt of repression by the military
government in El Salvador or the Senate
and east of government in Nicaragua I
was not there to pick sides and and I
think the great that was the great
benefit of having spent so many years
studying Christian ethics I was just
distrustful of all power groups and all
institutions
but once I got caught up in the milieu
of war I mean war is is is you know when
you're in combat it's it's very
frightening but it's also very high
octane existence right the rush the rush
the adrenaline rush abusement Park so
well it's it's it's probably the biggest
rush you're gonna get mingled with some
of the worst fear you're ever going to
feel and you know it is as kind of
zen-like experience where even colors
are brighter
you are aware or present in ways that
you never were before and if you can
control your fear you go back to seek it
out
again and again and again and it is like
a moth circling the flame and and and
the longer you spend in a war or
covering a war living in that culture
the harder it is to adjust because you
go back to a society at peace and not
only can no one around you grasp or
understand the experiences that you've
undergone the trauma you've undergone
but you can't find those rushes anymore
so that you will see as certainly with
war correspondents this frightening
pattern which is of course ended in the
death of several of my colleagues where
they will leave it Elizabeth knew fur
from the Boston Globe my friend Kurt
shark and miguel gil moreno are both
killed in sierra leone elizabeth died in
iraq Michael Kelly died in Iraq they
they pull away from it but you know
nothing in the peacetime life ever
replicates that but like any addiction
it ultimately is self-destructive
emotionally spiritually and finally
physically and I how did you as well I
too pulled back after the war of Kosovo
I have children and and and and the
Second Intifada I'm an Arabic speaker
the Second Intifada began in a
Palestinian uprising against the Israeli
occupation I and I was sent by the New
York Times back to Gaza and I went
willingly and I got caught on a very bad
Amber
at the Netzarim junction where a young
Palestinian teenager was shot through
the chest and killed about ten feet away
from me and I realized then that you
know that I had to get out that if I
didn't stop it was just a matter of time
before I was probably next or certainly
that the the odds were pretty good that
my luck luck wasn't gonna hold out how
what's been the the impact on you
personally is this the type of thing
that keeps you up at night yes of course
I mean you can't be around that kind of
you know raw physical violence and and
not feel the trauma of it some people
claim that they can compartmentalize it
or do whatever it is that they have to
do to keep it in a different place not
when you go to sleep nobody has control
over their sub-conscience when they're
asleep
and and and I have never met a veteran
who sleeps well because you know you
what happens is you you know you're your
sub-conscience goes places that you
don't want it to go and so you wake up
with a start often and these are very
debilitating nights it's very hard you
sort of you know getting up and getting
dressed and shaving and just going
through the motions of the rest of the
day are difficult and and that's why I
have you know the people I have the most
affinity with are usually Vietnam
veterans I mean we don't I don't have to
say much to them they get it do you
still yearn for that Russia no scares me
now let me I will take your questions in
a second I want to ask you one final
question to comment on upfront the the
role of the press in your writings use
describe the press is always part of the
problem yes well by that I mean if you
go back and look at the role of the
press at the inception of any conflict
at the national press let's say of the
press of the country going to war that
mingling a fear fear of what can happen
to us as a country in a society coupled
with the can of patriotism especially in
the age of the
electronic media where you're having it
you know pounded into your living rooms
with 24-hour news cycles is such that it
makes it almost impossible to go against
the grain within the entire society and
the press of course is no exception I
think that at the beginning of a
conflict the press feels that its role
ultimately is to sustain civilian and
army morale and what we get is not
reporting but shameless cheerleading and
if we look back at the coverage in the
lead-up to the war in Iraq when there
were serious questions that should have
been asked about you know Saddam Hussein
possessing weapons of mass destruction
or trying to build a nuclear device or
having links with al-qaeda I mean when
when the country desperately needed real
reporting we didn't get it we got
propaganda but when most people look
back and analyze what happened in
Vietnam they point to the press
abandoning the war there's the famous
moment when LBJ says we've lost Cronkite
yeah so where are we now are there
parallels there are parallels I think
that the most important thing to
remember about the press is that it is
the the main body of the press is a
reactive force there are very few people
in the press who will strike out on
their own
I mean well thank God there are a few
if's tone being the great example but we
have them today I mean Walter Pincus at
the Washington Post or Seymour Hersh at
The New Yorker I mean they're they're
not in large numbers and when you know
so you're also describing an elderly
gentleman where our where's the new
guard of journalists who are willing to
step out well you know some of the some
of the journalists in the Washington
bureau of knight-ridder for instance I
mean there was some real reporting but
their voices were pretty much drowned
out by this by the kind of lockstep of
of
disinformation that was disseminated by
the mainstream press including the New
York Times who at the time I was working
for but I think when public opinion
changes when the war moves from a mythic
narrative to a sensory narrative and by
that I mean when we're able to actually
just go in and report that there was a
car bombing without trying to stick it
within a mythic storyline then the press
is freed to report and I think that you
know that's an important thing to
remember in the Vietnam War that during
the war in Vietnam if you go back and
look at the beginning of the war you
know the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution which
again we now know was fabricated as an
excuse to get Americans involved in the
war or the incident that led to the Gulf
of Tonkin Resolution was fabricated the
press will go along until the public
begins to ask the right questions and
when the public begins to ask the right
questions the press is freed to ask the
right questions and I think that is the
moment we're seeing now we have gone
through a period where the the press
failed us where it did not report but as
the public is beginning to question the
enterprise the press is freed to
question the enterprise hi go ahead
please hi my name is Joshua Gross and I
am with the Center for Strategic and
International Studies in DC and I was an
English major literature major when I
was in college and in moments of self
reflexivity my friends and I would sort
of ask ourselves is literature necessary
and in your book you speak about this
sort of Redentor redemptive quality that
literature had for you personally as you
came back from some of these war zones
and were recuperating so my question for
you
mr. hedges is can literature have a
transformative power on a mass scale and
do you have any particular
works of literature books older new that
you think would be beneficial to certain
conflict regions say the Middle East or
the Balkans if they were widely
translated and disseminated well you're
a very astute I think to point that out
because literature for me kept me sane
and it kept me in touch with our common
humanity great writers Shakespeare
Marcel Proust Dostoevsky Tolstoy
understand human nature including the
darkness or the capacity for evil even
atrocity that all of us carry within
ourselves and I think that it's only
through that kind of understanding about
ourselves Primo levy the great Italian
and a Holocaust survivor writes about
this quite eloquently it's only by
grappling with those demons within us
that we can fully realize our own
humanity as long as we believe that all
of those demons are outside of us are
external and can be destroyed which is
why I think utopianist SAR so dangerous
we we become a danger to ourselves and a
danger to others and one of the things
that disturbs me I teach at Princeton or
will be teaching in the spring among
many of the great research universities
is the kind of withering of the
humanities they're not economically
profitable being an English major you
know it's not probably going to get you
a consulting job when you graduate for a
hundred thousand dollars a year or
whatever how much ever the financial
service sector pays these days when you
graduate but it is deeply important for
allowing you to reflect on how to live a
life with meaning and how to live a life
where you protect and foster our common
humanity in wartime
you know it's always interesting in
wartime societies because the first
thing though
who want to perpetuate a war do is
destroy their own culture before they go
on to destroy the culture of the other
they replaced that culture with
second-tier second-rate artists who are
willing to infuse the ideology of
patriotism and the glorification of the
nation into their quote unquote works of
art you know patriotic songs um you know
any any kind of play or theatrical
production or movie that glorifies the
nation and this isn't art this is
propaganda and and I think that one sees
that that art and and great writing and
not exclusively great writing but
artistic expression which is really at
it's at its most brilliant form a form
of social and individual self criticism
is very salutary
for the health of a community and a
nation so that you know the worst of the
totalitarian societies of the 20th
century had of course deep anti
intellectual strains fascism and
communism if you look at the Islamic
fundamentalist movements in the Middle
East even I think the religious right in
the United States there is a kind of war
against honest intellectual inquiry and
and so the literature for me is is is
more than just a pastime
it also allowed me to come back I can
remember coming back from you know a
particularly bad day and El Salvador and
sitting down and rereading Macbeth and
there's a scene where they come to kill
Macduff's children and the mother said
what I've done no harm and then and then
goes on to say but you know then I
realize I live in a world where to do no
harm can be accounted dangerous folly
and to do evil you know was rewarded
that that line and it's not a it's a
paraphrase just struck me so powerfully
and it gives you through the ages a kind
of connection a kind of continuity and a
kind
Comfort that there are people who
understand so and I think that if we
don't go back and look at the great
works that preceded us I think for
instance the Iliad is probably the
greatest work on war that I've ever read
I think the Odyssey is one of the
greatest works I have ever read on the
recovery of war if we don't go back and
learn from those who went before us we
end up leading lives of terrible
provincialism and narrowness thank you
Thanks hi and you said before that
people get obsessed they become they
almost need the myth of war and so what
do you think that it would be beneficial
to the popularity of a strong government
to fight in the war every few
generations or so that's a good question
you know we know that that there is a
kind of rallying around the flag and a
rallying around the government in a time
of crisis in a time of war we saw this
for instance with the attacks of 9/11
where the the Bush administration the
the poll numbers were dropping the
administration was somewhat adrift and
that catastrophic event rallied the
nation around the government at its
inception this is what always happens at
war and you know I don't want to impune
the motives of those who led us into
this war but there are critics who
believe that especially with the
elections that were coming up before the
war that that this was a way to pull the
country behind the President and this
does happen in wartime and it's one of
the reasons that those of us who write
about war and I think of course the
press as well must work very hard to
admit or and explain the reality of war
because if we do believe that war is
glorious and Noble and essentially
cost-free that somehow we
can walk in and fight a war without
large numbers of dead then it becomes
that you know that war is a form of
entertainment and we saw this in the
coverage of the first Persian Gulf War
where reporters were virtually never
anywhere near the fighting and all we
saw were sort of neatly packaged video
clips by the war makers if we don't
understand how venal and and and
destructive war is it becomes of course
much easier to wade into a war and
potentially a quagmire that we shouldn't
be in war should always be done with
great great reluctance and of course
always is the last resort Thanks I want
to remind you you're watching close-up
at the Newseum I'm John molesky this
week we're discussing war with author
and journalist Chris Hedges this is one
of mr. hedges books war is a force that
gives us meaning and it talks about the
myths of war we're discussing this with
students from McLane High School in
Virginia and also young professionals
from CSIS and I wanna let you know if
you'd like any more information on
closeup or any of its programs or our
partners here at the Newseum please
visit our websites it's www closeup org
and Newseum org and now we'll return to
our discussion with a question from this
young lady at the microphone hi my name
is Sarah fury I'm with the Center for
Strategic and International Studies and
my question is considering how much work
you're talking about goes into putting
to getting soldiers and civilians to buy
into the myth of war what institutions
or elements are necessary to get them
out of the myth of war and to function
again in a society or sleep well at
night who do you look to when you're
looking for information on anything in
this case war where do you look to to
garner the truth I mean I make sure I
read multiple sources I look at the BBC
I look at the Washington Post and and
magazines and I've read your book as
well so I try to incorporate theory into
as much news as I can get my hands on
okay well it's very hard especially in
the build-up to a war to find good
sources of information within your own
country it's very difficult within the
press
you'd be very hard you know that there
were there were almost no
voices of reporters anyway who were
doing real reporting I think you know
turning to ideological outlets that
always oppose war is probably no better
in the sense that it's information not
rhetoric that you must seek I think that
that that probably the best is to know
those kinds of writers who have a fierce
streak of independence i Hirsch comes to
mind and who are not going to get
bamboozled and swallowed up by this and
just very closely monitor what it is
they're doing but it's very hard it you
know it we used to when I covered the
war in Bosnia where everybody seemed to
have gone collectively insane whether
they were Croat Serb or Muslim make much
difference you know the joke was we'd
all thought we'd found sort of the one
normal rational person in an interview
but we but after 20 min we used to call
it a Linda Blair effect but of course
after 20 minutes their head would begin
to spin around and all this garbage
would spew out of their mouths it's it's
it's very very difficult and that was a
lesson I first learned when I covered
the war in Argentina for National Public
Radio out of Buenos Aires where before
they invaded the Falkland Islands the
hunt of the military hunt Oh which as I
said earlier it disappeared 30,000 of
its own citizens was about to fall the
economy was in shambles
they were the whole center of Buenos
Aires a couple weeks before the invasion
had been shut down because of protests
but the moment they invaded the island
that the country went collectively
insane and they were literally pulling
labor union and opposition leaders out
of prison cells with the marks of the
beatings on their faces and they would
get up in front of the cameras and go
las malvinas son argentinas the the
Malvinas which is the term for the
Falklands in Spanish belonged to
Argentina our Argentine and that was a
tremendous lesson for me that there were
you know to even criticize especially as
a foreigner even in any way the Hunta
which
was reviled before the war was to court
physical violence and those few lone
voices in Argentine society who spoke
out and they were very few were attacked
as unpatriotic and and with great anger
great vehemence and that was a
tremendous lesson for me that is what
that is what happens in a wartime
society Argentina is no exception
it happened within our own society it
happens in every society and if you're
aware of that it helps tremendously when
this kind of collective madness
nationalist madness grips a society it
helps to keep you focused and with your
feet on the ground let me let me ask you
a question and I raise hands do a little
quick poll and the choice is up front
I'm gonna ask you where you get most of
your news and the choice is our
television radio print Internet okay
those are the four choices where how
many people get most of their news from
television and raise your hand if that
describes where you get most of you then
let's take a look okay how I would say
radio I think one lone hand back there
how about a print source and then the
internet which i think is hard to
quantify because you're reading off the
screen or watching streaming video it's
a little both okay so what we saw here
was probably you would be elite by
national standards and in polls taken
time after time it shows that the
majority of Americans get most of their
news from television and in following up
on your question that leads to this
question about it is this nation if you
look at the 24/7 news cycle and we'd
call calling it news as being generous
in most cases is this nation capable of
having the level of sophisticated
discourse about issues of war and peace
if most people are getting their
information from television a television
isn't the problem I mean for instance
this is being televised but is the
problem to a commercial the problem is
commercial tel where the pressures on
ratings are so extreme
that news is judged not for its
importance as an item of news but it's
judged on its capacity to entertain and
there you know to exchange ideas which
is what we're doing today is requires a
lot of concentration and a lot of effort
to listen to to blowhard scream at each
other and insult each other which is
what passes for discussion on many of
these commercial programs is quick easy
entertaining funny and mindless and that
is what has destroyed television news
you know when I began in this business
now you know 20 plus years ago all of
the networks had foreign bureaus when I
covered the war in Salvador every major
Network had a bureau including CNN which
was a fledgling Network the reporters by
and large spoke Spanish they got up in
the morning they would go out they would
report a story they would produce it
they would put it on the air you know it
may have been too short three minutes
four minutes five minutes it may have
been a little too obsessed with what we
call the bangbang but it was still
reporting it was still journalism that's
gone it's vanished those bureaus do not
physically exist anymore those reporters
by and large are no longer employed by
these networks and you know the the
people we look at these very highly paid
news anchors who appropriate that
appropriate the title of journalists
have never reported a story at all they
interview famous people or they
interview important people or they
interview celebrities but I I really the
reporting skills are almost zero and
that has been a tremendous and
disturbing change
so that I think on most of the cable
news networks and most of the commercial
television stations they no longer do
news at all it's talking heads it's cute
it focuses on stories that you know have
the kind of lowest common denominator
something that will you know the the
sort of news equivalent of roadkill
something that will stop and turn your
head you know I we saw this with the
cover and coverage of by the embedded
reporters in the in this current war in
Iraq where they didn't actually report I
mean you know if you look if you analyze
what they did they they traveled with
military units who they were completely
dependent on for logistics they saw what
those units wanted them to see they went
where those units wanted them to go they
they knew very well that their personal
security and fate was tied to the
well-being of that unit and there is a
natural tendency to protect the people
who are protecting you that's something
I myself have felt not immune from it
but but it's not reporting especially
when you get into a situation and and we
all saw this on the television where
they would be broadcasting in real time
you know an explosion and there goes a
Humvee and I can see a Bradley and and
they act as sports commentators they are
describing to you what it is you're
looking at on the screen but in fact
there's no content you I think we know
less about this war and no context
exactly it is it is a verbal description
of what you the viewer seen in the same
way something like John Madden doing
work up exactly that's what it was and
that's not journalism hi I'm with the
Center for strategy International
Studies and my question is that
implicitly in your the title of your
book tell me if you disagree with this
that regardless of the consequences we
know that war is deadly and brutal but
regardless of the consequences
it seems that war is still a weapon of
choice by a lot of Polish
and do you think even but a population
in general do you think at the core of
it war as spirituality of war reflects
our own search for significance and our
own insecurity and that's why war can
never be abandoned in the long term well
that's a question I've struggled with
for many years and it's a really
important one in in Sigmund Freud's book
civilization and its discontents he
writes that the two most powerful forces
in the individual in the communal life
are what he calls the force of eros or
love that impulse to protect conserve
and preserve life and then what he calls
the impulse of Thanatos or the death
instinct that instinct to annihilate all
living things including ourselves Freud
wrote this on the e in the 1930s before
World War two again but certainly you
know as a great psychoanalyst capturing
the mood of Europe at the time and for
Freud these two forces were in eternal
conflict both within the individual and
society and one was always ascendant so
that I think that if we look at we at
our own country after our defeat in
Vietnam we became a better nation we
asked questions about ourselves we
hadn't asked before we were forced to
see ourselves as others sauce and the
site was not always an attractive one we
were forced to confront our own capacity
for atrocity and for evil and for this
we not only understood more about war
but we stood understood more about
ourselves but the war makers the myth
makers worked very hard over the
succeeding years to revive the myth of
war which culminated we went through
Grenada Panama culminated in the Persian
war and in Freudian terms that moment at
the end of the Vietnam War for us as a
nation was a moment of Eros and I think
that in Freudian terms the moment when
we we embraced war which had of course
at his core remember war is about death
it is about the physical destruction of
the other that's what the enterprise of
war is about and I think these forces I
think Freud's right I think these forces
are in eternal conflict and I think for
that reason like Freud I'm very
pessimistic about eradicating the
enterprise of war it is the type of
introspection that you describe national
introspection soul-searching is that
politically viable in any way I think of
Jimmy Carter's famous great malaise
speech and that made him a Republican
punchline right we're decades afterwards
and the reaction to that was morning in
America and Ronald Reagan right that's
you know and of course Jimmy Carter was
right you know I've always felt that
he's probably one of the great
underappreciated presidents he probably
a hard time finding a member of Congress
or the administration who would agree
with that well they know what sells and
you know never remember that or never
forget that just as the advertising
industry uses very sophisticated
marketing techniques to get us to buy
items or try and achieve positions which
we believe will give us more fulfilling
and meaningful lives and lives of
happiness
so now politics uses very much those
same techniques those that those forms
of mass manipulation to get us to
support them and if you look at
political debate it is about how we feel
or how we are made to feel about
candidates not about what they say or
what they think so you know I guess the
the moral of the story is that honesty
doesn't always pay I like to believe I
guess is a seminarian that in the long
run
does pay but clearly in the short run it
often doesn't hi
I drew Brisco from McLean High School
knowing everything that you know and
seeing everything that you've seen what
is your personal opinion about the war
in Iraq do you think it's justified and
necessary you know with all the violence
that you're aware of well I was I was
always opposed to this war and and and
and let me say that I was not opposed to
the first Persian Gulf War having spent
seven years of my life in the Middle
East and a lot of time in Iraq I did not
believe that in the first Persian Gulf
War UN resolutions were going to get
Saddam Hussein to leave Kuwait and there
is all those all that speculation that
if the Iraqi forces had been given a
free hand they may well have taken the
oil fields in northern Saudi Arabia and
I certainly believe that at least in my
understanding of the Iraqi regime that
is not far-fetched this war was
different first of all having lived
through the Persian Gulf War in 1991 and
then having remained in the Middle East
to cover the work of the inspection
teams the UN inspection teams and
knowing the stockpiles of weapons that
they had destroyed knowing what a shadow
the Iraqi military was compared to what
it had been before 1991 I had a very
hard time believing that Iraq was a
threat to his neighbors much less to us
I knew that the Baathists the Baathist
regime under Saddam Hussein hated the
Islamic fundamentalists I mean I I had
covered you know they were ruthless
towards Islamic movements within their
own country and I never thought the war
was necessary and because you know I'm
so reluctant in terms because because I
know the cost on the ground of violence
I was very outspoken against the war
this I did at some personal cost because
the mood of the country was such that
many people didn't want to hear
I commend speech shortly after President
Bush landed on the aircraft carrier and
talked about mission accomplished where
I at Rockford College in Illinois where
I was booed off the stage my microphone
was cut people actually tried to climb
up on the stage to push me off I was
taken out in the middle of the ceremony
by campus security and then there's a
memorable commencement address and yeah
at least they won't forget it
and and then of course the the trash
talk radio Rush Limbaugh and these
people had a feeding frenzy and and the
the paper of the New York Times my
employer issued me a letter of reprimand
that coming out of the newsroom I was
was formally told that I was not allowed
to or I had impugn the impartiality of
the New York Times that was a difficult
moment for me
you know I'd spent 15 years with the New
York Times it's a great newspaper but
you know I really had to go back you
know into my own experiences growing up
in a manse with a very outspoken father
who spoke against the war and was active
in the civil rights movement and worked
in the gay rights movement a later part
of his life to understand that you know
I could pay fealty to that institution
in my career but to do so would
essentially to be muzzled on an issue
that I felt strongly about and that I
had a great deal of knowledge about and
I remember after being called into the
office in New York and being formally
given the reprimand and the physical
written reprimand being put in my file
and told that I had to be quiet which I
no intention of doing I walked out and I
realized that that the gift that my
father had given me was freedom and and
that's the greatest gift you can have
because any institution even
well-meaning institutions will try and
own you and they will try and own your
conscience and and that for me is just
not a life worth living so was it that
we didn't go to war for the right
reasons or was it that more is just so
awful
that no war is justified I I think we
didn't go to war for the right reasons I
mean I lived in Sarajevo during the
siege and I fully understood why
resident of that city surrounded by Serb
forces that were dropping upward upwards
of 2,000 shells a day on them I
understood why they would go out and
literally man trenches to try and keep
the Serbs back that did not save the
residents of Sarajevo from the
pernicious effects of war in that you
know those people who had a penchant for
violence rose to positions of power the
gangster class organized the first
militias and when they weren't Manning
the barricades they were usually off
looting the apartments of ethnic Serbs
who lived in the city and oftentimes
murdering them so it doesn't save you
from the poison of war but there are
times when you are faced with your own
physical destruction the destruction of
your family the destruction of your
community the destruction of your nation
and I think at that moment it I don't
like to turn just war but war becomes
inevitable and and and and anybody I
think at least in moral terms it's
understandable as to why they would use
violence to try and protect themselves
and protect those around them but that
does not save them in the end of course
from the the evil consequences of war
and the damage that war does to them as
individuals and to the society at large
thank you hi hi my name is Chelsea
Peterson from McLean High School and you
talked about how Wars become a form of
entertainment in our country especially
and how it has penetrated the media and
books music and popular movies and
everything and I was just wondering if
you think that the media has changed our
connotation of war in the American
soldier and whether the necessity for
war in the media will continue to
perpetuate over time or whether it will
eventually dissipate
I think that you know when you go back
and look at you know even all the way
back to the ancient Greeks or you know
you know when you read the Aeneid that
myth that warrior myth is just a really
powerful myth within almost all cultures
especially Imperial cultures and I think
what's
different is the way we would
disseminate the myth but the myth has
always been there and I think will
always be there you know there's no
shortage of great memoirs by people who
have been through combat and have come
back and written about the reality of
war but it's painful it's painful to
read it's painful to hear it's painful
to understand and I think when you talk
to people who come back even you know
these soldiers and Marines are coming
back from Iraq they'll sit around and
people will ask them how it was and and
if they really start to tell them it
most people begin to get really
uncomfortable really quickly the fact is
a lot of people don't want to hear the
only people who really understand war
are the people on the ground who see it
because the images however disturbing
they may be are so sanitized and so in
and and of course the ones that begin to
to reflect any kind of truth so
infrequent that we're spared from seeing
how horrible war is and when people come
back and try and and lay it out for us
it's painful to hear people prefer to go
back to the myth there's a kind of
natural gravitation back towards the
myth this is I'm trying to figure out
the gravitational pull for the press
assuming let's assume let's give benefit
of the doubt that this is not purposeful
propagandizing is is the common thread
here the narrative the need of a
narrative you have mythology the main
vehicle for dispersing mythology is
storytelling the main vehicle for
journalism is storytelling right is it
looking at this chaotic battle in front
of you and needing to impose some
narrative thread onto it that well you
know that's a good point but you know in
a because when you're actually in a
situation of combat the the most all the
time you're just completely confused
you're desperately trying to figure out
where the firing is coming from it's
often coming from you know more than one
place or your friends friendly fire yeah
and and and you only see a tiny little
you know there's a small perimeter of
stuff that you could you're actually
seen I mean the landscape of
you know even a firefight is beyond at
the moment your ability to comprehend
and grasp so what you do when when
fighting ends is immediately try and
create a narrative to make sense of it
and that in many ways is what the press
does for you it takes what for the
individual is completely confusing and
makes a narrative well the press knows
very well and and I and I think it's
probably not always conscience conscious
but they they they understand in a kind
of reflexive way what the best narrative
is and that is you know who was heroic
where are those you know refugees or
people who were repressed who have now
been liberated by our you know heroic
troops and and what are the perfidious
crimes of the enemy that fits into a
very comfortable mythic war narrative
that allows that is the framework by
which many of them seek to understand
what's happening but more importantly
it's that framework that the people at
home expect hi please hi I'm Sam
headland from the Center for Strategic
and International Studies it seems to me
like your work on trying to find some
kind of middle ground in how to go
forward in more if we find ourselves in
war without being seduced by it and
corrupted by it for I you could take
exception to this but I see a certain
commonality between that and certain
realist thinkers like Reinhold Niebuhr
and so I'm just wondering what utility
do you see in philosophical reflection
on war and what where do you think that
could take us Sam terrific question and
I'm sorry to do this to you but about 30
seconds for an answer
Reinhold Niebuhr Czar great of course
influence I mean you were right to cite
him I think that we want to look at
people who understand human reality
always be wary of utopianist
and cynics and
understand as Niebuhr said the decision
in life is never between moral and
immoral but usually between immoral and
more immoral and once you realize that
it becomes a lot easier to make choices
okay thank you gentlemen
sorry to rush your and your answer these
are a couple of the books from Chris
Hedges
about war interesting reads we would
highly recommend them I want to thank
you for your questions and comments
throughout the discussion I particularly
want to thank Becky Sipos and her
students from MacLean high school and
also Dan Gregory and his well students
of life I guess you call them employees
at CSIS thanks to all of you for joining
us next week when we return to the
Newseum our discussion will be about
reporting on religion that's our version
of a holiday program I guess hope you'll
join us then until then for all of us at
the Freedom Forum Museum and close-up
foundation I'm John molesky thanks for
watching